[Music]
okay everybody I am honored today to be
joined by Liza de Oliveira aka dodge aka
EKKO aka well lady aka Lucas aka Gabe
I'm doing great how are you I love on my
aks yeah you got a ton to like how
awesome this character is and it's how
complicated a character of Dodge is now
the main thing that was I was wondering
watching the show was when you were
playing dodge as an actress are you
playing it in your head as a demon or
was it easier for you to like pretend
that she was a real person
I definitely try to play her as a demon
as grounded as possible the one time I
tried to play her as a person is in
episode 7 I believe where she
infiltrates the family and so I think
there she really had to use her
manipulative powers to you know the nth
degree to get Tyler Tyler Tyler in and
so that's when I try to be as human as
possible but when I wasn't doing that I
definitely tried to infuse as much demon
like qualities in a grounded way that I
could see that makes so much sense and I
think it's interesting you say to that
like you did tap into that demon part
which is pretty cool and I wonder when
you talked a lot of actors or actresses
that play villains they always usually
have sympathy for their character even
though they are the villain they see
that in the person were you able to find
sympathy for such an evil character you
know I didn't feel like I had to for
dodge because at the end of the day
she's not a human being
hmm she's an echo and so she's an echo
who's used the identity key to be in
this form so for her it's just about
having fun in this new skin that she's
wearing
and getting what she wants it does
nothing else matters she's the only one
who matters and so really I just tried
to dive into that as much as possible
and have fun with it running off of that
is that hard to do did you find like
finding from scene to scene like the
motivation of her character or was it a
little easier than a bill really not
really because it was about getting the
keys and manipulating everybody to get
the keys so if I just focused on the
keys like that was my objective right so
whatever I had to do to get there that's
what I was thinking about the entire
time so whatever I had to do she doesn't
really have a moral compass so I wasn't
really worried about you know what her
motivation to get the key was the
important thing is that she needed them
and so I just every scene I think I was
just thinking about keys keys keys how
am I gonna get this and I'll do anything
takes a lot a nice person so what does
that mean you know to me I love that now
if I'm gonna say I would compare you to
for what Johnny Depp is to Tim Burton
you are right now to Joe Hill where
you're in in the tall grass do you feel
an immense pressure like getting these
big rolls from beloved novels and
graphic novels like how did you take
that I mean I think it was just a lovely
coincidence to be honest when I booked
in the tall grass I would say that was
my first kind of big girl job and so you
know I read Stephen King and Joe Hill
and I was over the moon and then
lock-and-key came along
and I saw that it was Joe Hill's
material and I thought oh well maybe
this will help me because you know I
just did in the tall grass and I think
my team was just like you know we don't
really know if it'll help you just go in
and do the audition and I did and it was
just and I don't even think he knew that
I was reading for dodge it just ended up
being a lovely coincidence
when when the I think the showrunners
had decided that you know I was a pic
and she had seen it it was just ended up
being a lovely coincidence and not only
that vincenzo natali who directed in the
tall grass directed the final two
episodes of lock-and-key so it's such a
great reunion yeah and and then I ended
up doing an audio book or an audio story
for Joe Hill full-throttle
and I read the story called thumbprint
and that was great and I was like wow
what's next do I get invited to
Christmas dinner yes I'm just joking I
mean he is such a lovely lovely human
being and I just feel so honored to be
around him and to be able to make his
source material come to life because I
feel he's very talented she that's
that's the smart answer see now he's
gonna cast you in everything forever now
you are yeah and you you just do an
awesome job bringing these characters to
life it's such props to you and people
from the graphic novel fans of it love
this character of dodge and it's such a
cool character now when you go into that
is there any other like famous villains
from other movies or books or shows you
use to kind of like inspire your take on
dodge you know the funny thing about
playing a woman especially in sci-fi
world is that there aren't many of them
and there wasn't a lot for me to pull
from that's why I was very excited that
you know dodges form especially in the
first season was primarily going to be a
woman and so when I went to you know
find who I could watch the arena
character I could kind of think up with
Maleficent Angelina Jolie ignored the
bed so I definitely watched that and
tried to do she's really great and that
the way she walks
you know you
to kind of see like okay so I have to do
something with my eyes I have to do
something with how I walk with my body
movement especially if I'm wearing you
know an epic villain outfit so I pulled
from that but that was the only one I
could kind of watch and I'm watching
other bad guys and some ones but they
they didn't have that sci-fi element to
it sure so it was a little bit tricky
actually just watched His Dark Materials
oh yeah yes she's great with doing in
that blew me away but that was after I
had shot walking cane like oh I wish I
had seen this before because she was
terrific yeah that yeah it's funny you
say that because I just watched that too
and it was like yeah it's like watching
both of those shows lock and key and His
Dark Materials you see like these great
woman villains coming out and yes yeah
that's Wilson and now you it's like it's
really really good to see and I'm sure
sorry I'm not thinking about work the
thing is with dodge I think Ruth Ruth
wrist character is still very much well
they're not humans but you know there
isn't that team and aspect to it and
which is so cool because she's able to
be very vulnerable and with dodge dodge
isn't vulnerable so it's finding that
sort of fine line of just being a
complete garbage being still trying to
be likable yeah absolutely
switching gears a bit I was going to ask
you two when we see Dodge I think one of
the most humorous takes on Dodge is that
you know she devours food at an
incredible rate are you doing this take
to take are you really putting that much
food your mouth just actually yeah that
was a hard scene to shoot thankfully our
director Michael Morris gave me a spit
bucket so I wouldn't swallow all of the
food and it was actually quite hard too
because it was all carbs right and you
actually wouldn't go down my throat so
when they would go
cut I would fit into the bucket and
there was a lovely ad who would hold the
bucket for me and a lovely makeup artist
who would wipe the drool off my face it
was not glamorous at all and I remember
shooting that scene and you know Michael
asking for more like more devouring you
know this meal and there you know when I
drink some maple syrup remember the
first time I did it as I went to do that
I thought wow the actor to me was like
what a great acting choice the human
being and me was like you are an idiot
you're gonna have to do this 40 times
now and so that was really funny but it
really worked
I eat a lot more than you saw - I
remember eating like eggs and it was it
was I couldn't eat for the rest of the
day that's for sure that's a little bit
gross but I love this game I absolutely
love it so speaking of that - what was
their specific like favorite scene for
you that you filmed in season one I
really loved the finale I did some
really cool wire work which I had never
done before so that was really fun for
me I also love episode 7 when I learn
Tyler in because that was one of the
first times for me where I got to really
act with the main cast I mean a lot of
my scenes are with Jackson who plays
Bodie but it's aren't allowed to work a
full day I believe they only get eight
hours I'm not quite sure and so he would
go home and you know I would have to do
a lot of the scenes without him just
with this picture double and so that so
that would be quite challenging because
you're not doing your scenes with you
know the actual actor so I would just
have to remember what he did and then go
in and do my coverage and so when I go
and I start to learn Tyler and then I
start to you know act with the family
that was really fun because that was the
first time I was getting to act with my
cast mates and they're all so town
so I had a really great time feeding off
their artistic energy versus just you
know dancing by myself or doing it with
a guest or doing it on a green screen
that's really cool to hear that like
you're also mastering all these like
trades of the craft having different
scenarios and like you're saying with
wires and green-screen that's pretty
awesome so my last question for you that
I've pretty much asked everyone in the
cast at this point I'm gonna ask you
because people really wonder this what
if there was one key that lies low would
want that in your life oh to be hmm
probably like a tidy key okay a custom
key it would clean my house it would
pack for me why could it would like wash
my hair I hate doing that it would do
things for me a maid tea I don't know
and practical I mean you can have all
the magic in the world and I will just
want to keep that clean for house which
i think is hilarious
but that's where I'm at in my life you
know that look I love the honesty that's
great
Liza is there anything else you'd want
to plug besides lock and key at this
moment anything we can look forward to
yeah I actually have a film that should
be coming out this year I don't know the
dates yet but it's a thumb by director
Adam McGowan and was actually at in
competition at the Venice Film Festival
and there was a tip as well it's called
guest of honor and it's lovely drama and
I'm very very very different in it so
she's definitely tuned into that when it
comes out of theaters that's an exciting
tease okay so everyone here heard it
from her yourself and obviously check
out lock and key on Netflix we want to
get a season two so any views just keep
clicking and watching and share with
your friends your family it's a great
awesome show and Liza absolutely crushes
it as the villain of Dodge Liza thank
you so much for joining me
and
I hope to talk to you again soon me too
thank you so much this is lovely